oh my lands i flacked him there how did
that how did i do that
how did i just do that
all right guys i gotta focus during the
game so i don't really be answering too
many questions
so drop i don't have any i don't have
any rook lifts down
yeah i'm really tied down here
let's let's do a magnus style exchange
stack
should have made a knife
oh my god
i'm gonna lose on time though all right
yes pre-moving is good
he's gonna sack a piece that's a good
move
very practical play
oh yeah and he's gonna win probably
all right how does he look perpetual
it's not over
[Music]
[Music]
i should have knocked my king over why
would i pre-move that
just walk my king over
let's just um can you see seven can be
six
i can really escape
what's up
[Music]
wow what is he sitting there for
oh god i wanted a piece here
i don't know what's going on
wow
my knight on h5 was defending there
i gotta go kimchi son
now trade queens and this should be
winning
okay
let's start attacking defend
now we want to swing the knight around
to e3 i feel like i've done nothing
except move my knight in this game
don't i have this thought
okay can i get away with this i think i
can
yeah i definitely can now can i get away
with this and then this
and then this lobster pincer
he's gonna go bishop v6 or something
[Music]
mix
hmm complicated i'm winning a piece here
so
that's mate
it's like a petrov on steroids
you can go here
go here
don't like this maybe i can simply
simplify this place you can
go here and then prima d5 that was a
risky premium
now let's start attacking him
try to flag him here
we lost on time
okay
[Music]
23
oh this is very strong
okay but i actually win this one it's
not so bad
this is a win okay
unlike some of you i don't really care
about the rating so i won't stop here
i slept like six hours i don't know what
you guys talking about
i don't like this position
i'm gonna try to sack the bishop and
push the pawns
okay
draw i should have played a little
faster though but i was trying to save
my pawns
fine i was completely lost when i lost
the piece
let's go for activity lay him down a
couple pawns here
this is probably going to be a loss but
we'll see
this is a nice game by lyrasa
okay too slow too slow
i already had this
whoa that's a free queen
just don't want to give them any chances
here
all right
okay we're supposed to give the bishop
here
okay now i'm trying to clamp down on
these weak squares that he's got
let's go here
okay
[Music]
let's go drop six
yeah losing this one
all right
no i've had this mouse i mean it is a
new mouse but i've had it for like two
months it's the g pro super light
it's the new logitech it's really good i
can recommend it
i'm just getting lucky most games and
just
here's what it is and this will probably
turn around
oh my god he mouse lift and i didn't do
anything but it's still good
yeah it resigns
i'm blind okay it's not over i can take
a screen
or take this one
hard for him to untangle here that's
interesting
okay this is interesting yeah but
probably he's got too many pawns here
let's see
yeah i've got two little two coupons
okay
this is bad
thank you for the three bucks
oh my god no i'm starting to play badly
okay i'm going to increase this every
morning
now i have this okay let's go
productivity
now i'm playing badly
this one's in the can
now we gotta reset the win streak here
yeah this just was e4 with a horrible
endgame
and loaded the pawn
slow down a little bit
yeah but i thought i'm better
maybe
yeah there was no no shot there to win
this one i should be able to win
of course
i can't defend the pond
oh my god
very bad
should be winning
all right all right
okay don't let him catch up i mean i
appreciate the support but
i'm doing my best here he's good he's
playing better than he was at the start
he was really tilted at the start so
okay it takes time big whoop
he's gonna go rook a3 at some point
obviously he's gonna take the pawn or
something
the key is to not pre-move
this is the wind
alexander and i alexander and i need to
work a little bit on
her ability to mate in these positions
and her ability to flag in these
positions that's one of the things we'll
do during the drill
c6 right
it's one of the crucial skills in bullet
this ability to like flag people into
versus work positions and stuff like
that
oh he's got this freaking
goodbye you
there's more calculation than people
realize i mean you do calculate some
lines
you you try to calculate minimally but
you do calculate that there's
no doubt about it it's not just you're
just moving the mask
if it was then the video gamers would be
fast it would be the fastest 30-second
flip it was just about mass movement
and all the res i'm sure would agree
with me
but don't i have this if he takes takes
21 king age 2.85
you q1 g5 g3 queen b2 king g1
queen c1 f1 wins see i wasn't
calculating
oh god okay let's sack the knife
why did i do that
stupid it's very stupid stupid stupid
stupid okay
it's very stupid this is america and
they cannot play bullets
queen is actually trapped yeah goodbye
that was once i lost the night of the
summer
i'm playing dirty i'm playing
i'm i haven't done a single dirty thing
how am i playing dirty i don't believe
you said that
many people like to i'll rest is my boy
he wouldn't say the same
also take it as a compliment
okay he wants this flag the living
daylights out of him here
at least i'm going to try where he's
going to just
outplay me in a down down obstacle
bishop end game yes he is
okay but i can go here i can win one of
his pawns
no it's probably losing actually
where is it what if i go king off
that was dirty now that was dirty i i
confess i confess
that was a dirty move the echo thank you
but that's what you got to do in 30
second chest
i was not like this before oh he is
saying it
but but this is we've always done this
i'm actually playing
more cleanly than i used to i don't know
what he's on about
i'm actually trying to play proper chest
here
for the most part
there's a little stuff you pull in 30
seconds that's normal
i don't know i don't buy it
100 business
another one in the can
there's an accident
so
yeah he's going to win the spawn in the
game thank you
man gifting blackstone
let's see if i can flag him
yeah too much do a little time
oh my god oh bishop basics yeah i didn't
expect to take
the pawn
this should be pretty crushing
that was a i wonder what the accuracy
was i think other than bishop basics
that was a good game
i think i played a legitimately good
game there
once knight f5
does it change first well i've gotten
older i'm older i'm wiser well
none the wiser i guess but i'm younger
at heart
i don't know in what context he means
these words
[Music]
you cannot pass on me it's not stalemate
i forced him to unpassana then it's me
that's why i'm
okay i've got a good night but that's
about all i've got
okay it's gonna make me careful
yeah it's basically made so i've gotta
sack the night and
try to seek some kind of play with my
pawns still got some play
but no he's got too much material here
that's right brandon that was a good
game
okay what is he sitting there for
trying to put the pressure on him
thank you mentor himself something
all right i couldn't e5 the one move to
flag me
unbelievable
then it happens
thank you
i was that dirty i just needed him
okay let's allow queen f7
benoni is good in 30 seconds
okay let's simplify the position
prophylaxis
free exchange
it's not entirely open oh my god now it
is
very poor
hmm
[Music]
yeah he didn't primo i thought he might
pretty much
yeah i'm gonna get them headed here i
gotta open the center
hmm
oh my god i'm walking into these easy
tactics
elementary tactics
again
gotta win a couple here
let's go
he plays this better in 30 seconds than
some people i know in classical
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
i'm going to lose a proper piece
hmm
what's going on
[Music]
okay i don't see it i'm just taking him
yeah this line
[Music]
[Music]
oh my god i should have gotten maybe
seven if i just fit
amen
gotta win a couple here just to extend
the lead again
it's playing like a machine these couple
couple games here
weather the storm
okay now i gotta win this next one is
very important
very important game here just to get
back on like a good
good run
okay the next one is also very important
get him to get him tilted again
super important
of course i lose
yeah i managed to lose that one
my magic
yeah he's the best supreme over in
history i mean
i can compete but like he might be the
fastest player to ever walk the earth
like his combination of strength and
strength and and accuracy
is unmatched
he's gonna lose on time he's gonna flag
well well he's drunk
that was a miracle save
he's not happy about that one
what i'm doing
yes got him there again
all right all right we're building it
back up
slowly bit by bit
wait now i just take
and i played a horror playing response
and i'm missing some chances here
i think i can just take
just as long as i don't blunder [ __ ]
man
how does he do that
okay at least we got a pretty clearly
defined position
wait how did he take so quickly he
pre-moved green beans
and thera thank you i don't understand
how you're able to execute that move
so quickly it's like it took him a
millisecond to
get the queen from that side to the
other
that's what i talked about whoa oh
that's a free window it's not here here
1968 back to d6 and see oh a1
c3ba here it takes defended
oh it was a brilliant game and it's mate
made on the back ring
what's up penguin and we got we're
graced by
the two i'm playing and then the chat is
the best type of goal player in the
world
yeah this is already lost with alireza
you cannot get a pawn down position like
this
let's try to break up his pawns and he's
got queen d5
well there's a knight there's always
going to be some chances
ridiculously good play i think i could
have done there
can i go here no sees it instantly
this is bad for white
[Music]
man i'm not stopping from taking all my
pawns
unbelievable
[Music]
just unbelievable
i want to win but still that was to come
back from that position is crazy
these days
i'm not too worried about this i'm
worried about the pawn yeah
got a great chances somehow
i gotta go at five maybe
yeah but i don't really have anything
here
oh
jesus
all right got him that was a big win
now i'm playing poorly i was against
sandra a million times
these kinds of positions are very hard
to play in 30 seconds
thank you and the bits really appreciate
the support guys
subs thank you everybody
oh my god the queen is saying stupid
now i'm watched it and now i'm worse
he has no moves just paralyzed though
thank you another 100 bits
let's hype it up
he's gonna go bishop v6 i was about to
say he's gonna go bishop b6 and he did
he just gifted me a game there
i'm happy if he wants to spot me some
games
okay 100 bits we're gonna get some
fibonacci action here
okay this is i might as well well this
is not resignable but it is basically
these positions are just
what am i doing
now i gifted him a game
well some life here
yeah i let him finish the development
and it's over
wait i can take here maybe
not yet over still probably lost
okay not anymore he just busted up that
one i mean that was just winning
completely
out of the opening out of the gates
yeah this is like magnus duboff
we need to get our king the hell out of
there
foreign
and a flag and another one is in the can
thank you drill at the office appreciate
your subs
oh my god only alireza has bishop c5 in
that position
gonna give me some check
that was great pre-moving there at the
end by me
she's gonna go bishop queen take a shoot
i mean i'm sensing
you might do something dirty
holy smokes charlotte chess center
that's a big boy dunno with 10 subs
what's we call and he just that's what
we call a big boy
sub gift thank you sir
coach peter gift enough subs that's what
we're talking about
get the hype going boys all right
should have taken that
yeah i mean i was trying there but
hard
do
wow that was a safe
thank you pj pj gifting us up there we
go that's awesome thank you pj
yeah we need to avoid i need to probably
go 1v4 or something because this
structure is kind of killing me
not good in this structure i think
oh as i say i blundered the bishop
forgot to take on f6 first
accident
now he premiered that
okay we need to do something about that
structure
this is lost
i think he's flying like a computer
i thought i could do this probably we'll
play on this game
shadows in my face
come on e5 is so simple
oh my god i should have taken a screen i
was just i why did i pre-move that
that was so stupid that was a dumb primo
such a dumpling
come on
cash
i flagged him though so we curb the
bleeding there
so
get three pieces
[Music]
i should have oh my god it just
it's finished
okay i have some compensation not
anymore
why would i do that
56 are you kidding me that's a
ridiculous move
all right
that was nice big time save right there
it's a free knight and that's our
resigns and there we go
now we're talking ladies and gentlemen
this is actually theorem that's not
clear
not supposed to give up knight like this
e5 you're winning peace
okay now we take here here here
take attack
here here
here here
he will probably take and take but okay
then i think i'm going
to probably but okay thank you guys soon
it's an interesting line i think
why would i do that okay we gotta run
from one side to the other run
this is okay
oh my lands i flacked him there how did
that how did i do that
how did i just do that
oh damn i got checkmated there basically
why do i go for these openings
yeah this is lost
that was just like i just gifted them
that game
this is a bad position
gotta change things up a little bit here
okay this is fine
everybody's going to go a5
i don't think b3 works
oh my god i've got freedom i shouldn't
agree with that
horrible shooting the frame of that
now i'm starting to blunder everything
absolutely everything
of course the prim of knight g5
seriously
we're gonna go to games let's see if i
can avoid losing the next 13 games
i'm playing like this and of course i've
done it again
unbelievable
so accurate it's crazy
it's just crazy
yeah i have to win one again
this is a good chance see if i can score
how's it
all right we got him big game big game
big game again now we gotta win like 800
and we'll be good
now i'm lost right out of the opening
oh no no no okay doesn't matter
over this up
oh i won that holy smokes that was close
let's see if i can string together two
in a row
nope all right it already doesn't seem
that way
how does he never make premium mistakes
ever
now
nope can't win two in a row
that's another horrific move
um
i don't losing everything now
run run run run
stem the bleeding okay that's 50. got 18
more to go
see if i can get at least 50 percent
good why am i like just leaving that
pawn
god should have activated this
of course i have one second always
just have only one second
um
oh my god
[Music]
oh okay flagging which is good
i'm gonna win the 100 game match but by
how much is the question
and will i have a decent rating at the
end of it
so
[Music]
it's hard to take down it is oh my god
he is so hard to take down
oh my god barely barely i
barely want that one
but i didn't that's what counts
okay if he wants this he's going to take
b2
which i just offered up for no reason i
wanna back though
i'm happy with my king safety
okay i have a bunch of pawns now
how do i defend this i don't like that
it's okay
once i get active pieces
oh that's me that's a sexy mate
i did not expect that to be me
here we got a sack here
oh and look at that move
rock him cowboy look at that move
queen h3 knight f2 is mate
all right now we're talking
okay we're playing to a hundred games i
hope that's fair i hope that's okay reza
i have to go after that
thank you chess kid appreciate the raid
welcome guys playing
30 second chess with all your as a
ferruccia
basically the best 32nd player on the
planet
i'm gonna go bishop
another one in the can
300 beds thank you
what was that
at least now i can defend the farmer
okay can i go here
okay okay he's gonna go bishop e5 and
blast me to death
so we gotta create some counterpoint
here's rookie five but now i go here
check it's close
i blended with me i mean there's nothing
i can do about it
yeah it's over
i mean i tried my best there but he's
just a
master of that stuff
no premium mistakes ever
knights are generally good in 30 second
chess
but he only gets
unbelievable i won that okay
home stretch guys can we do well on the
home stretch
no no no no no no no no okay i did not
expect i thought a knight b6 is the only
move
it's okay oh my god you dirty
uh well i didn't wasn't paying attention
so dirty
not that i don't do the same thing i do
it's not over though
there's some game left and i've learned
a knight which she doesn't take
just gotta stop him yeah okay that's a
good move
okay
drop well i drew down a piece which is
good
this is equal i think
no no no no no no no no no no no
i even saw it as i was putting it there
that was dumb
stupid
okay that's a free prime
inexcusable blender okay let's go here
yeah i don't like this at all i don't
like having two pieces in
30 seconds
what i do like is trapping rooks though
i do like trapping ropes that that i do
like
you're you ain't doing nothing lyrisa
not this time
can
oh it's over 104 oh we played over 100
okay i think that's probably enough then
yeah but i have a lesson i need to go
sorry guys i need to go
so we're gonna we're gonna declare our
last five
the last five starting now
oh my god come on why would i take if i
would prefer the next move
an idiot come on
okay we need to go rectify the pawns
all right four
[Music]
okay here's the window
oh three
[Music]
i'm up a piece but i'm not even better
two
no oh my god what am i doing
what am i doing
facebook
different ones last night
please
one last one here we go
this is not going to be a good one is it
good games good games early rosa that
was a good match it was a great match
i gotta run guys i'm i'm really tired
and i i have a lesson i gotta prepare
for
i got four lessons actually so i'm sorry
but i'm i'm all done for today
oh my god that was a crazy match um
i hope you guys enjoyed it
good games to elireza it's an honor
truly
[Music]
you